[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de transition démocratique t que l'ont
décidé les militaires qui assurent
actuellement l'intérime
pouvoir les spécialistes du monde arabe
évoquent une probable HDE de choc après
la Tunisie et l'Égypte d'autres pays
pourrai être touchés le dénominateur
commun une jeunesse ad de liberté face à
un régime imposé quelquefois depuis plus
de 30
ans et puis en Syrie des manifestations
contre le régimes se sont soldés hier
par la mort d'au moins qu personnes et
aujourd'hui les forces de sécurité ont
tiré des gaz larimogènes lors des
funérailles de de
manifestants
[Musique]
en
2011 à la suite d'un ce qu'il faut
appeler un fait d'iver en
Tunisie un tout petit incident la mort
d'un homme certes mais un tout petit
incident se déclenche par vague
successive extrêmement rapide un
mouvement révolutionnaire qui saisit
pratiquement tout le monde arabe Bachar
al-Assad se croyait à l'abri des
révolutions arabes mais depuis le mois
de mars le peuple syrien est dans la rue
une révolution réprimée dans le sang qui
marquera peut-être le crépuscule du clan
des lions
[Musique]
àassade
en Syrie après le le printemps arabe de
2011 une révolte populaire contre la
dictature de Bachar al-Assad il y a une
répression terrible qui va s'installer
qui va s'engager qui va déclencher un
conflit qui sera la guerre de Syrie et
qui sera aussi une guerre civile la
répression est d'une violence absolument
incroyable enfin il fait tirer dans les
foules il fait tout simplement tirer
dans les
foules ce que Mbarak n'a pas fait ce que
Ben Ali n'a pas fait
ce qui ne s'est fait dans aucun des
autres pays
[Musique]
arabes c'est une politique de la
terreur on bombarde les hôpitaux on
bombarde les les quartiers civils mais
les hôpitaux surtout on par
systématiquement les hôpitaux et puis
naturellement on bombarde des jours et
des jours et des nuits et des nuits
nonstop nonstop
Halep qu'il faut
[Musique]
récupérer
dès ce moment-là le gouvernement de
François Hollande mouvement que je
dirige se prononce en faveur de
négociation politique en faveur d'une
solution politique dans tous ces pays en
particulier en Syrie j'ai pris la
décision de
reconnaître la coalition
comme la représentante légitime du
peuple syrien et j'ai même ajouter une
conséquence c'est qu'il y aura un
ambassadeur de de la Syrie en France qui
sera désigné par le président de la
coalition et bon il y avait une
concertation une ébullition dans les
capitales on a Hollande en France on a
Madame Merkel en Allemagne on a Obama
aux ÉtatsUnis c'est pas des barbares
c'est des gens qui ont un
cœur on peut les aimer politiquement ou
pas mais ce sont des gens qui ont un
cœur évidemment et et donc il y avait
cette ébullition et il y avait une
pression sur Obama parce que les
Européens même pas la France ne ne
pouvait faire quoi que ce soit de réel
sans sans un appui logistique des
[Musique]
États-Unis vous savez au début le
président Obama ne voulait pas soutenir
concrètement l'opposition parce que pour
lui euh ça mené à quoi n'oublions pas
qu'il était élu en en parti en
s'opposant la guerre en Irak c'estàd en
s'opposant au changement de régime
moyenant au aux interventions militaires
américaine et donc il voulait pas
participer à à cette guerre donc il a
hésité mais après les massacres euh du
régime euh il est devenu impossible de
ne pas exiger le départ de d'Assad et
une fois qu'on on avait demandé le
départ d'Assad il y avait des
conseillers le secrétaire d'État le chef
du CIA et cetera qui qu' lui conseillait
de de fournir des armes à l'opposition
mais Obama ne voulait pas parce que pour
lui c'était l'engranage on commence à
soutenir l'opposition et après on va
nous demander de d'intervenir
militairement et il voulait
[Musique]
pas
comme on est sur l'optique d'une
solution politique on adresse des
avertissements et effectivement Barack
Obama trouve cette formule qui
correspond à l'état d'esprit de la
France aussi hein de la Grande-Bretagne
des Européens d'Allemagne aussi il y a
une ligne rouge qu'il faut pas franchir
et les ligne rouge c'est l'utilisation
des armes
chimiques on savait très bien que Bachar
al-Assad avait des des dépôts très
importants euh d'armes extrêmement
dangereuses parmi les plus dangereuses
au monde dans ce domaine-là et la ligne
rouge c'était ne touchez pas à
ça le concept de ligne rouge c'est un
concept très classique en diplomatie ça
consiste tout simplement à dire n'alllez
pas plus loin sinon il va se passer
telle ou telle chose en 2011-212
les États-Unis improvisent une ligne
rouge sur l'usage de l'arme chimique
syrienne tout au long de l'année 2013 il
y avait des cas soupçonnés de d'armes
chimiques est-ce que c'était vraiment le
régime qu'il a fait est-ce que c'était
vraiment l'armes chimique c'était sans
doute des armes chimiques mais on ne
savait pas vraiment parce qu'on avait
pas des inspecteurs sur le terrain on
avait pas de de militaire donc on
soupçonnait mais n'oublions pas que les
États-Unis déjà dans la guerre d'Irak
soupsonn la présence de d'âes de
destruction massive et ns nos experts de
renseignement s'était trompé on avait
[Musique]
t and links to terrorist
groupsellour
[Musique]
ifam sa of our people and for the of
[Applaudissements]
il y a un pays en Europe un pays
important en Europe qui est la Grande
Bretagne le Royaume-Uni qui va suivre
George Bush avec son premier ministre
Tony Blair qui va faire une erreur
majeure et dont on va voir les
conséquences plus tard et qui va qui
monte à la tribune de la Chambre des
communes et qui dit nous avons les
preuves de l'existence de destruction
massive comme le ministre des Affaires
étrangères américains nous avons les
preuves quand il s'exprime à à la
tribune du Conseil de sécurité de ces
armes de destruction massive et en fait
on va s'enapercevoir que ces armes
n'existent
pas le le le régime est assez astucieux
c'estàd que pendant tout un temps il va
jouer avec la ligne rouge al jouer avec
la ligne rouge c'est notamment ne pas
utiliser franchement et directement des
produits chimiques
militaires dement constitué mais de
mélanger à des explosifs classiques
notamment dans les bar
qui sont balancé par les hélicoptères
euh des produits primaires chimiques
mélangés à de l'exclosif ça a l'avantage
de polluer des des zones de provoquer
c'est pas nécessairement létal mais ça
permet de neutraliser d'avoir de de
créer une terreur une peur d'être dans
une certaine Z zone euh c'est assez
documenté par des ONG par des
journaliste à l'époque sur le fait que
les les les les enfants les femmes
pleurent ont des irritations de peau et
cetera et donc il y a suspicion
d'utilisation d'armes chimiqu mais
artisanal
entre c'est l'une des attaques les plus
violentes perpétrées par les troupes de
Bachar alAssad depuis le début de la
guerre civile elle aurait fait 1300
morts décs par dizaines aligné au sol un
linceul blanc pour les
couvrir ces images auraient été tournées
à douuma au nord-est de la capitale
impossible de le vérifier impossible de
savoir à quoi ils ont succombé nous
avons choisi de ne pas diffuser toutes
les images qui nous parviennent
certaines sont
insoutenable la plupart
invérifiable celles-ci ont été tournées
par un vidéaste amateur devant
semble-t-il un hôpital de la bonlieue de
Damas euh l'utilisation d'armes chimique
en août 2013 était différente des cas
précédent euh dans le sens qu'il était
clair que c'était régime le régime et et
que c'était d'une grande envergure
c'est-à-dire que ça a tué plus de 1000
personnes danst plus de 400 enfants on
se souvient qu'il y a exactement 1 an
Julian le 21 août 2012 et bien Barack
Obama avait expliqué que la ligne rouge
à ne pas franchir c'était précisément
l'utilisation de ces armes chimiques
alors encore faut-il pouvoir la prouver
c'est pour cela et bien que l'ONU va
probablement pouvoir demander ce soir
que ces experts qui sont sur place et
arrivés à Damas dimanche dernier et puis
bien puisse avoir accès au témoins au
lieu afin de pouvoir vérifier ou pas
l'utilisation de ces armes chimiques et
c'était une attaque dans une partie de
de de Damas qui était contrôlée par
l'opposition et donc il y avait la
motivation était claire et donc en
rassemblant toutes ces données était
très clair que c'était des armes
chimiques et c'était le régime qui était
[Musique]
responsable
what weve seen in Syria are appalling
scenes of death and suffering because of
the use of chemical weapons by the Assad
regime and I don't believe we can let
that
[Musique]
stand
tout porte à
croire que c'est le régime qui a commis
cet acte abject le massacre chimique de
Damas ne peut rester sans
réponse et la France est prête à punir
ceux qui ont pris la décision
infme de gazer des innocents je vous
rappelle qu' ce moment les Russes disent
mais ça vient pas du régime ça vient des
des
opposants
l'histoire qui s'est déroulé le 21 août
selon nos analyses était fabriqué de
toutes pièces et c'est pour ça qu'il y a
besoin d'enquêter alors enquêter de
façon officielle par les Nations Unies
c'est ce qui va se faire mais ça
demandera un peu de temps mais aussi les
services de renseignement que ce soit
les services de renseignement français
ou américains qui vont très vite
recueillir les preuves qu'il y a bien eu
des massacres avec l'arme les armes
chimiques utilisé par le régime de
Bachar alAssad et et ces militaires
rapidement dans les dialogues qu'on peut
avoir au niveau internationaux et la
France est un des rares pays occidentaux
à avoir des moyens d'appréciation
complètement autonomes et ça je le je le
soulligne donc on n'est pas dépendant
sur ces moyens d'appréciation simplement
de de renseignement américain et bien on
s'aperçoit que Bachar al-Assad et s
confirmé a utilisé des armes chimiques
contre sa population le responsable de
cet usage odieux d'armes chimiques en
Syrie ne fait aucun doute
le régime
syrien l'histoire nous jugera
tous si nous détournons les yeux sur les
agissements d'un
dictateur qui utilise des armes de
destruction
massive malgré les
avertissements ça nous devons le
savoir Obama est M il est président des
États-Unis il a dit il a dit si
j'interviens donc il doit
intervenir il doit tellement intervenir
que l'intervention se prépare
franco-américaine et très vite on va se
concerter avec les Américains les
Britanniques les Européens mais en fait
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a que trois pays
qui sont prêts à prendre une mesure de
rétorsion d'avertissement pourquoi ces
trois pays je crois qu'il y a il y a un
consensus plus large mais la la France
les États-Unis et le Royaume-Uni sont
trois pays qui ont la possibilité parce
qu'il faut le faire vite ce sont trois
pays qui ont la possibilité de réagir
vite politiquement et vite militairement
avec un un spectre large de de capacités
militaire pourquoi politiquement parce
que vous avez des pays en Europe qui
doivent passer par tout un débat
parlementaire avant d'engager des forces
et et et là on n pas le temps et c'est
même et ça serait même très
contreproductif au niveau de l'effet de
surprise et de la confidentialité qu'on
veut garder alors c'est intéressant de
voir comment les Occidentaux cherchent à
réagir parce que ils n'ont pas de enfin
les trois pays qui sont impliqués les
trois grands États-Unis France
Grande-Bretagne donc trois des CIN
membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU n'ont pas de mandat de
l'ONU puisqueévidemment à l'ONU les
Russes et les Chinois bloquent toutes
les résolutions d'un point de vue russe
si chaque fois qu'une population rebelle
contre ces autorités si ça provoque une
intervention occidentale de l'OTAN les
États-Unis pour éliminer le régime ça va
jusqu'ù d'un point de vue russe de notre
point de vue c'est une bonne chose la
démocratie fin de dictature d'un point
de vue russe c'est menaçant le choix des
objectifs militaires doit être à
l'évidence un choix politique un choix
diplomatique et donc ce qui est fait
c'est de définir toute une série de
cible ayant un lien avec le chimique
donc sont ciblés des sites de stock dès
lors qu'il n'y a pas de risque de
propagation s'agit pas en faisant
exploser des obus chimiques répandre de
produits chimiques partout donc il y a
des analyses qui sont faites là-dessus
des centres de commandement des intérêts
liés au au chefs militaires notamment
appartenant à la famille Bachard qui
sont dans la chaîne chimique donc tous
ces objectifs sont analisés après il y a
un deuxième objectif et qui est là
beaucoup plus clair dans la tête des
Français qu'il ne l'est dans la tête des
Américains pour les Français et à mon
avis juste titre on est à un moment clé
dans l'histoire de la guerre en Syrie et
à ce moment-là l'armée syrienne est en
grande difficulté et on estime à tort ou
à raison qu'envoyer un signal militaire
fort mais B
limité vis-à-vis du régime pourrait
conduire
Infiné à renforcer l'opposition et à
effaiblir encore un peu plus le régime
donc il s'agit pas il s'agit pas du tout
d'une opération de changement de régime
mais on espère qu'un bénéfice de cette
opération pourrait être on est on est
quand même à un moment où il y a
énormément de défection dans l'armée où
l'opposition armée est forte elle n'est
pas encore
djihadisée donc on espère et ça c'est un
peu l'objectif secondaire de l'opération
que ça aura un impact sur le cours de la
guerre mais cet objectif là il est
beaucoup plus français qu'américain donc
il y a une effet qui se coule hein on
envoie un message politique très dur à
Damas et à ses alliés on l'affaiblit on
l'affaiblit pas militairement encore que
on va à l'occasion de ces frappes casser
les chaînes chimiques donc ça enlève un
avantage militaire à à Bachar mais on ne
réduit pas son potentiel militaire on ne
on ne frappe pas ses aérodromes ses
stocks de munition C PC de commandement
et cetera donc c'est pas une entrée en
guerre premier effet deuxème effet on
soutient la
rébellion ensuite il y a une troisème
raison c'est tout simplement de dire bah
la ligne rouge a été franchie il faut
faire quelque chose parce que sinon
notre réputation va en souffrir Bachar
alAssad va penser que euh nous ne
respectons pas nos engagements et donc
il peut y aller
et par contre on a une surprise qui est
une surprise politique euh c'est que à
ce moment-là David cAmr Cameron alors
qu'il est pas obligé de le faire décide
de de demander au
[Musique]
Parlement Cameron avait assuré Obama
qu'il réussirait que oui ne vous
inquiétez pas on va la faire il pensait
vraiment pouvoir pensait
vraiment remporter sinon facilement en
tout cas remporter ce vote à cause de de
la gravité même des faits enfin cette
cette attaque chimique c'était quand
même d'une telle gravité les images
étaient tellement insoutenables que il
pensait vraiment que malgré le précédent
iraakien il n'aurait pas de de
difficulté à à obtenir le le soutien du
Parlement à Londres les députés
britanniques ont refusé que leur pays
participe à des frappes contre la Syrie
infligeant un camouflé à David Cameron
j'étais même avec lui le jour avec le
président le jour où la chambre
britannique a voté et il nous a posé la
question au conseiller alors qu'est-ce
que ça change justement exactement cette
question est-ce que ça change notre
approche et personne ne lui a conseillé
de d'arrêter d'un point de vue
opérationnel on peut faire sans problème
cette cette intervention cette frappe
ces
frappes en partenariat
franco-américain je crois que nous on
était prêt en tout cas et les Américains
on a en ont parfaitement les capacités
assez rapidement donc il est décidé de
de le faire à partir d'une de frappe
aérienne et de frappe aérienne
essentiellement tourner à partir de de
missile de
croisière euh la France en a dans son
dans son arsenal donc les britannique en
avait et les Américains en non les
Américains décident d'utiliser leur
marine c'est-à-dire de tirer des
missiles de croisière à partir de navir
prépositionnés et nous pour garder la
grande confidentialité on décide
d'intervenir mais à partir d'une base
aérienne en
France il y a des bases qui font
décoller les avions radars des bases qui
vont faire décoller les les tankerss et
puis des bases qui sont pour les on
avait quelques mirages de 1000 en
accompagnement et puis et puis et puis
essentiellement le le la mission a étit
faite par des par des
Rafale et donc le 29 Obama dit
organisons un Conseil national de
sécurité pour demain euh pour
préparer la réponse pour être sûr ce
qu'on va faire et comment et cetera et
même à la fin de cette réunion auama'a
dit on va merci beaucoup c'est décidé on
va on va y aller et donc nous qui avons
participer à à la réunion après c'est
c'est le l'après-midi du 30 août pensons
que ça y est demain on va attaquer on
était d'accord avec la
France j'ai été informé dans la journée
de samedi que le Président de la
République François Hollande avait
convoqué un conseil de défense qui était
envisagé mais plutôt que prévu le samedi
en fin de journée donc je suis rentré à
Paris et je me suis rendu à l'Élysée
j'étais un peu en avance pour la réunion
du Conseil de défense et François
Hollande me dit je vais recevoir un un
appel téléphonique de Barack Obama si tu
veux viens
assister à titre évidemment confidentiel
à à cette à cet échange très important
peut-être qu'il veut aller plus vite que
prévu enfin il était confiant donc on
était nous on était prêt tout était
organisé avec les l'étatmajur pour que
l'intervention puisse être effective les
pilotes sont aux avion leur a
déclenché et donc au début de
l'entretien tout se passe
bien très a très sympathique cordial et
Cera et puis petit à petit on s sent
poindre quelque chose et là il faut que
je consulte le
congrèsit against sy
regeets would not
openendvtion we would not putots on
the instead our would desed to limited
and
qui veut consulter le Sénat mais comme
le Sénat n'est pas encore en session ce
sont les vacances parlementaires on est
le 31 août les frappes devaient avoir
lieu le weekend il renvoie ça au plusôt
au 9
septembre
[Musique]
et on s'est regardé avec François
Hollande une fois que la conversation a
été terminée on s'est rendu dans la
salle du conseil de défense et là avant
d'entrer il me dit bah faire tout seul
là on s'est senti un peu lâché d'une
certaine façon d que dans une initiative
qui faisait sens qui était aussi ce
message la communauté internationale et
donc c'était
l'application de de de la la
proclamation d'Obama sur la ligne rouge
mais on pouvait pas le faire
seul
[Musique]
nous les conseillers étions surpris
parce que même à l'époque on n'estimait
pas avoir le le soutien du du
congrè d'abord il reste un président qui
il le répète en permanence n'a pas été
élu pour commencer des guerres mais pour
terminer des guerres donc il est très
réticent vis-à-vis de l'emploi de la
force militaire surtout au
Moyen-Orient deuxièmement il craint une
escalade militaire parce que l'idée de
dire on va faire une frappe symbolique
qui va secouer un peu le régime et
réduire la menace il y croit pas
beaucoup il a raison de penser à ce qui
peut se passer après mais il ne veut pas
être engagé dans une escalade militaire
et lorsqu'il dit j'ai décidé d'y aller
et de consulter le Congrès c'est une
manière de dire je suis à peu près
certain que le Congrès ne donnera pas
son aval surtout que la chambre des
commune britannique vient de dire
qu'elle s'opposait à l'intervention je
ne dirais pas que c'est à cause de ce
vote négatif qu'il y a pas eu
d'intervention en Syrie euh mais il est
clair queobama qui était déjà très
réticent à y aller s'est appuyé sur ce
vote pour dire bon mais si les
Britanniques n'y vont
pas on va trouver une autre
solution on va pas y aller seul on va
pas y aller juste avec les Français
c'est évidemment un prétexte c'est
d'abord parce que rien ne l'obligéit à
consulter le Congrès alors bon il
pouvait avoir pensé que politiquement il
était obligé mais institutionnellement
il ne l'était pas et jusque-l il l'était
d'autant moins qu'il avait prévenu son
pays le Congrès publiquement en disant
ligne rouge donc s'il était intervenu
bah bah oui il tenait parole bon et non
c'était un prétexte évidemment pour tuer
l'opération les Français évidemment sont
euh sont choqués les avions comme on le
sait les avions sont déjà en train de
rouler sur le tarmarc le président
Hollande avait été extrêmement affecté
de ce que j'ai pu en voir comme chef
d'état-major par cette utilisation
d'armes chimiques humainement vous voyez
c'est au-delà du droit et et la réponse
politique humainement et je crois je
l'ai mesuré par la suite il a cru
pendant longtemps que le président Obama
n'avait jamais voulu y aller
euh ce qui était pas notre perception à
nous parce que je peux assurer qu'avec
le militaires américains on avait soigné
le détail et que c'était pas simplement
pour pour faire du vent on il y avait
vraiment un ordre des Américains d'y
aller et c'est juste dans les jours qui
suivent qu'il devientent de plus en plus
clair que le Congrès ne vait pas que ne
va pas voter de lui donner
l'autorisation et finalement au bout de
ce
processus de désengagement la France va
se retrouver tout seul avec ses bombes
sur les bras et à ce moment-là contenu
du fait que la la portée politique de
ces éventuelles frappes et complètement
vidé de sens la France se trouve dans
l'impossibilité d'aller frapper toute
seule le le
régime je ne pense pas que la
Constitution des États-Unis soit un
outil pensé par les pères fondateurs
pour qu'un président des États-Unis
échappe à sa
responsabilité de chef de l'exécutif et
de commandant en chef des forces
armées c'est aussi un consensus
interne
nécessaire
impératif pour respecter la démocratie
des États-Unis cette légitimité à
intervenir cette responsabilité de
protéger qui est au cœur de toute
l'administration Obama depuis son entrée
en
fonction héritière de deux guerres
qu'elle n'avait pas causé cette
responsabilité de protégé qui justifie
l'arrêt des hostilités en Irak et la
conclusion d'une guerre ne peut
justifier à son tour l'ouverture alors
que l'Afghanistan est toujours béante
l'ouverture d'un nouveau conflit qui ne
serait pas multilatéral qui ne serait
pas consensuel qui n'aurait pas la
légitimité de la communauté
internationale une intervention
militaire en Syrie n'est plus à l'ordre
du jour du moins dans l'immédiat c'est
le message délivré ce matin par François
Hollande qui recevait le président de la
coalition nationale syrienne tout doit
être fait
pour une solution politique on était
vraiment coincé parce que à ce moment-là
les choix étaient de ne pas répondre ce
qui est assez dramatique étant donné la
ligne rouge et les Alliés
euh et ça permettrait à çaad de utiliser
encore une fois les armes chimiques
parce que pourquoi pas si on ne va pas
répondre ou d'agir sans l'accord du
Congrès qui est aussi assez dramatique
euh ayant demandé l'accord donc on était
vraiment coincé et c'était uniquement à
ce moment-là et en fait même des années
plus tard je ne sais pas ce qu'il allait
je ne sais pas ce que ce qu'il aurait
fait Obama face à ces de
choix tellement difficiles mais on ne
saura jamais parce que c'est à ce
moment-là les Russes proposent de
travailler ensemble pour éliminer les
armes chimiques la proposition surprise
de la Russie hier accepté par la Syrie a
permis de desserrer momentanément les
Tau le régime de Bachar al-Assad
accepterait de se débarrasser de son
arsenal chimique en toute
transparence désormais Moscou gère les
affaires du monde avec Washington fin
les humation l'accord signé à Genève
avec les Américains sur le
démantellement de l'Arsenal chimique
syrien est présenté par la presse comme
une victoire
russe je remercie Poutine d'avoir évité
les frappes pour moi il mérite le prix
Nobel de la
paix le plan russe c'est une
improvisation totale de la diplomatie
russe qui effectivement va permettre à
la fois à Barack Obama de sauver la face
et Vladimir Poutine d'apparaître comme
quelqu'un qui essaie de régler des
problèmes à
Saint-Pétersbourg un journaliste demande
à John carerry euh est-ce qu'il y a une
façon d'éviter la la guerre est-ce qu'il
une face qu'est-ce qui serait nécessaire
pour éviter une attaque américaine et la
réponse de kry c'est oui il y a une
possibilité Assad n'a qu'à accepté de
donner de de abandonner tous ces stocks
de de d'armes chimiques et quiryajoute
pour souligner le fait que c'était pas
vraiment une proposition mais il va pas
le faire parce qu'il peut pas le faire
donc on éétait pas c'était vraiment pas
une proposition parce qu'on estit
sceptique les Russes entendent ça et ils
se disent bon c'est pas une mauvaise
idée de de éviter la guerre
en en travaillant avec les Syriens de
pour éliminer leurs armes chimique c'est
là un enjeu considérable édifier sur
place des ateliers robotisés pour
détruire M et substance t l'hyérite le
VX le sarin les services de
renseignement français estiment à 1000
tonnes les dépôts syriens qu'il faudrait
garder 24 heur sur 24 pendant une
dizaine d'années le délai avancé par
certains spécialistes pour achever le
démantèlement la Russie et les
États-Unis n'ignorent pas cette réalité
pour neutraliser leur stock de 30000
tonnes les experts américains
prévoyaient par exemple 15 ans il leur
faudra finalement près d'un quart de
siècle les 35 milliards de dollars pour
y parvenirah on est un peu sceptique
mais en même temps pourquoi pas il faut
faut il y a une initiative diplomatique
effectivement qui sera saluée par les
Américains euh ça n'empêche pas Banky
Moon le secrétaire général des Nations
unies de dire que le régime de Bachar
elAssad a proféré dans son pays des
crimes contre l'humanité donc il y a
cette C ce constat de la violence de la
brutalité de ce régime qu'il fait subir
à son peuple donc nous nous ne faisons
pas d'illusion mais après tout pourquoi
pas essayer à condition qu'on puisse
vraiment contrôler que les contrôleurs
de l'iaac va fassent vraiment leur
travail partout sur le terrain et et
nous nous avons par nos services de
renseignement un certain nombre
d'indicateurs qui montrent que les les
Syriens jouent double jeu mais enfin
c'est difficile de se mettre en travers
d'une initiative qui va apparemment dans
le bon sens c'est une
entloupe il s'agit pour la Russie
d'inciter la Syrie à signer la
convention d'interdiction des armes
chimiques et donc à se débarrasser
volontairement de son arsenal chimique
alors c'est une entourloupe pourquoi bah
tout simplement parce que ça ne règle
pas le problème de ce qui a été fait
c'est un pays qui en 10ans ne pas avoir
d'armes chimiques vient les utiliser sur
sa population civile et puis surtout
comme les Russes le savent très bien ça
n'est pas quelque chose qui va aboutir à
la destruction de l'Arsenal chimique
syrien la Syrie va déclarer un certain
nombre de stock en cacher d'autrre et
donc c'est un peu la pire des situations
même si ça sauve la face pour Obama
et aussi pour Bachar etassad parce que
ça donne le sentiment qu'on a réglé le
problème alors qu'en fait il reste
entier comme on le verra dans les mois
et les années qui
[Musique]
suivent
les Russes qui ont une stratégie de
créneau c'est-à-dire comment arrivver à
exister à redonner à la Russie une
certaine puissance diplomatique alors
que c'est un pays qui a le le le PIB
grosso modo de l'Espagne qui est un qui
a un budget militaire inférieur à la
France qui a de grosses difficultés de
projection de ces moyens militaires qui
a des moyens militaires qui restent
relativement importants mais c'est
vraiment pas une grande puissance pas du
tout une économie qui était fragilisée à
l'époque par l'effondrement du prix du
baril de de pétrole et donc là Poutine
cherche des opportunités pour se refaire
un peu de gras sur le mou euh des améri
américain et là je reprends l'image
d'une journaliste du Monde syie Koffman
qui dit le monde aujourd'hui est partagé
entre les carnivores et les herbivores
les carnivores se
régalent du fait que le plus carnivore
d'entre eux des États-Unis se désengage
et abandonne ses
camarades de combat c'est ce que les
Américains ont fait en se désengageant
de de de Syrie en plantant les Français
en plantant les Français là Barack Obama
qui refuse de de respecter sa parole et
qui plante s ses alliés français donc
nous sommes dans un monde de
chambardement complet des relations
international c'est un paysage
complètement fragmenté avec un retour
des puissances nationalistes il y a pas
de désengagement américain même pas au
Moyen-Orient il faut quand même rappeler
que Obama et Trump sont intervenus
militairement de nombreuses fois au
Moyen-Orient ce qu'il y a en
revanche c'est une succession de deux
présidents Obama puis Trump qui disent
moi je veux pas commencer cette guerre
je vais les terminer et qui disent moi
je veux d'abord m'occuper de l'Amérique
et je pense pas que les États-Unis
doivent être présents en permanence dès
qu'il y a une crise dans le monde les
États-Unis ne veulent plus être le
gendarme du monde bon c'est leur
droit et après tout ils n'ont pas
toujours et c'est un underatement vous
le comprenez était un si bon gendarme du
monde on ne va pas pleurer là-dessus de
toute manière c'est un fait c'est comme
ça mais quand on on a été pendant si
longtemps le gendarme du monde qu'on est
devenu après la chute du mur de Berlin
la seule superpuissance militaire et
économique on ne peut pas se décharger
du jour au lendemain de ses
responsabilités sans
contribuer un minimum à la
réorganisation de l'ordre international
ou plutôt à la recréation d'un nouvel
ordre international au moins une
tentative de il est vrai que cette
tendance à être moins concentré être
moins le bouclier je dirais spontané de
l'Europe face aux menaces c'est une
tendance historique à mon avis qui date
d'Obama et qui va qui s'est accéléré
avec Trump mais je ne pense pas que Joe
Biden reviendra sur cette doctrine bien
sûr la France aimerait que tous les
Européens raisonnent comme elle ça n'est
pas le cas il y a une confiance en
l'Amérique qui existe encore notamment
dans un pays comme la Pologne
euh qui est infiniment supérieure à
celle que la France a dans ce que
peut-être le soutien américain est-ce
que l'Europe devrait en tirer des leçons
la France le pense tous les Européens ne
le pensent
pas l'Europe que nous connaissons est
trop faible trop lente trop inefficace
le temps où la France propose est
revenue et cette ambition doit être
portée maintenant c'est le bon moment
cette année en plein brexit Emmanuel
Macron a voulu mettre l'accent sur la
coopération européenne première troupe à
défiler l'initiative européenne
d'intervention créée il y a un an cette
force armée regroupe aussi bien des
Français que des Danois des espagnols ou
des Estoniens 10 nationalités unies pour
des missions conjointes un peu plus tard
la brigade francoallemande actuellement
déployée au Mali fait son entrée au
milieu des corps traditionnels de la
défense la France comme leçon de
l'épisode de 2013 que le récit qu'elle
porte depuis 1958 à tort ou à raison
c'est que l'Amérique ne peut pas être
éternellement l'allié sur lequel on
s'appuie les États-Unis ne doivent pas
être la puissance vers laquelle on se
retourne en permanence pour régler les
affaires du monde donc il y a une espèce
de validation à travers l'épisode du
2013 de ce ce récit historique français
qui est très fort dans dans l'ADN
politique de notre pays
et qui nous conduit à dire bah
l'Amérique est un grand pays c'est un
grand allié nous partageons beaucoup de
valeurs et d'intérêts en commun mais
nous ne pouvons pas nous fier à elle il
y a beaucoup de leçons pour les
Européens dans dans cette affaire et
c'est une question pour les Européens
mais il est vrai que il semble que
l'Europe n'a pas l'unité et la force
nécessaire de d'être un acteur
euh qui peut agir sans les États-Unis on
voit ça en 2013 quand Barack Obama
décide de ne pas frapper c'est la France
qui doit suivre même si c'est une
décision prise à Washington on doit être
à la recherche de capacité européenne
pour faire ce type de chosl sans les
Américains il était logique de le faire
avec les Américains s'il le souhaitaent
mais sans les Américains s'il ne
souhaitent pas
intervenir 7 ans de guerre et l'horreur
qui continue en Syrie avec ses lourds
soupçons d'attaqu chimique à Doua dans
le secteur de la Goutta les hommes de
Bachar elAssad auraient attaqué selon
plusieurs ONG les rebelles à l'aide de
gaz toxi attaqu condamné par l'Union
européenne par la France mais également
par les
États-Unis j'ai ordonné aux forces
armées des États-Unis de lancer des
frappes de précision sur des cibles
associé aux capacités du dictateur
syrien Bachar alAssad en matière d'armes
chimiqu
une opération conjointe avec les forces
armées de France et du Royaume-Uni une
attaque massive a lieu en
2018 et que c'est là que les Français et
les Américains vont déclencher l'aripost
c'est trop tard puisque la guerre a
beaucoup évolué depuis 5 ans on n plus
du tout au moment où on peut dire que le
régime vacille c'est trop tard parce que
l'opération de 2013 qui était envisagée
comme c'était pas une intervention au
sol c'était pas une intervention massive
c'était une intervention qui avait aussi
un caractère politique et qui avait pour
but de déclencher une nouvelle dynamique
diplomatique pour que le le Conseil de
sécurité se saisisse de cette question
qu'on puisse aborder les choses
autrement mais à partir du moment où les
conditions n'étaient plus réuni que
l'influence notamment de la France des
États-Unis de la Grande-Bretagne s'était
affaiblie c'est option s'éloigna de plus
en plus évidemment toujours difficile de
d'imaginer ce qui se serait passé s'il y
avait eu cette intervention hein euh
peut-être la situation serait pas
meilleure aujourd'hui mais enfin en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est qu'elle est
très mauvaise et que les Occidentaux ont
perdu beaucoup de terrain et beaucoup
d'influence dans dans cette région
depuis pour l'instant en 2020 la
diplomatie en Syrie
a est contrôlé et par les les Russes les
Iraniens les Turcs et les États-Unis les
Européens ne sont pas vraiment même à la
table et malheureusement euh Assad
toujours au pouvoir et des perspectives
pour la série qui sont très
[Musique]
négatives